uh let's bring you more on our breaking
news just a few minutes ago the european
union's health regulator recommended
authorizing astrazeneca's coronavirus
vaccine
for all adults uh let's get over to step
vassen who's uh
outside the medical agency in amsterdam
what news of this
latest development step
well it's interesting that the the ema
the european medicine agency has now
approved
the asta zenica vaccine for all age
groups so this is the third vaccine
that can be used in the european union
against covet 19.
there was this talk before that there
might be a limited approval so people
above 65 would not be able to get the
vaccine but the
ema has decided not to go along with
this despite the fact that germany
really insisted on this
i'm sorry age limit they say that
despite the fact that the
the vaccine has been tested only in
groups mostly in groups until
55 years of age they have found enough
antibodies in also elderly people who
have been given the vaccine also in the
uk but also in the trial
to reassure people above 65 that it's
safe to use they say
there will be more information coming in
along these
the next couple of weeks so these
updates will also
maybe reassure people even more that
this vaccine is
safe to use for everyone basically all
age groups